vous accueillons aujourd'hui marche à
mettre bas rhône président de
l'association racines l'association
racines oeuvre pour le développement
social économique et culturel de la
communauté maghrébine en quelques
bonjour bonjour merci à l'invitation
bienvenus vous organisez cette fin de
semaine un hommage à la femme maghrébine
du québec
et ceci à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits de la femme
pourquoi un tel hommage
en fait c'est une tradition qu'on s'est
engagé à le faire parce que on croit
vivement que la femme d'origine
maghrébine il contribue activement au
développement économique et social et
culturel dans la société québécoise et
canadien est malheureusement une bonne
partie de ces femmes là et l'oeuvre dans
l'ombre et sans pas aussi connu une
liste pour le public maghrébin nîmes
pour le grand public québécois et
canadiens à chaque année on est des
lauréates possibles dépendamment de la
thématique et l'orientation qu'on a
défini et c'est une hache à son compte
vraiment c'est une très belle découverte
pour le grand public
alors vous vous parlez de la thématique
donc si je comprends bien chaque année à
une thématique qu'on parle de cette
thématique
et comment se fait le choix des fins ok
on n'est pas là son dénigrer le travail
que vous faites ce n'est pas le choix
d'un prix nobel
donc comment ça se fait est ce qu'il ya
un comité d'abord il ya le français du
racine qui qui est qui met des leaders
mais par contre ayant cédé plusieurs
partenaires du racing qui font partie de
l'association
mais ce sont des partenaires engagés
crédit lui qu'ils ont une notoriété qui
chacun dans son milieu
alors ils le savent qu'on a voilà la
thématique voile et le profil des femmes
qu'on cherche et n'ouvre aux nôtres aux
90 rencontres avec les les candidates
ont fait notre cherche à nour
enfin l'offre à 102 qu'est-ce-qu'il
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont contribué parce que
nous on cherche pas forcément juste le
travail de la personne qu'est ce qu'il
fait comme travail mais c'est quoi au
delà de son travail qu'il est sans
engagement dans la collectivité
qu'est ce qu'elle fait de plus au delà
de son travail
c'est ça vraiment le critère qui est
essentiel qui fait qu' il ya des
lauréats qui a été nommé au nom et
pourquoi c'est important de célébrer
pour vous regarder je trouve que la
communauté maghrébine en général
élever énormément de défis et les corps
malheureusement au niveau de celle et
alan kelly post est même au delà de
comparer à d'autres communautés qui
valorise les légendes et ceux de leur
communauté
tian sans les nommer mais il ya
plusieurs cours noté qu'ils font ce type
d'événement duquel plusieurs années ça
les valorise
et puis ça permet au grand public
omidyar de découvrir certaines personnes
et ça c'est ça qui fait que certains
femmes par exemple ils peuvent faire le
saut en politique il te veux aller à
devenir des membres de conseils
d'administration des c'est ça qui fait
que au lieu qu'ils travaillent dans
l'ombre c'est un conte sérieusement
quand leur donne une possibilité m
comme ethos dans les cimes de soi et qui
seront capables de faire plus qu ils
font des genres pour influencer le
réseau restreint mais qu'ils allaient ça
plus que ça j'ai quitté cannes aux
auditeurs que c'est vrai que nous sommes
deux ans en train de parler d'une
thématique de femmes là il ne s'agit pas
de prendre la parole en or mais c'est
juste que vous vous êtes sur le terrain
donc vous adaptez de cette association
j'imagine que racine offre des services
aux femmes maghrébines service aux
autres vous allez me l'expliquer pendant
vos interactions avec les femmes qui
viennent à votre association
quels sont les défis que de la femme
maghrébine
ici au québec c'est qu'elles soient
nouvelles ou nouvellement arrivés ou
qu'elle soit qu'elles soient immigrantes
depuis longtemps vous savez d'abord je
tiens c'est vrai qu'on parle pas au nom
des femmes mais je tiens quand même à a
bien précisé que racine sa réussite et
faire vraiment grâce un engagement
significatif de plusieurs fins et autres
qui croient à la mission de racine et et
de faire la différence
malheureusement le défi qu'ils vivent la
femme maghrébine et très grande dans le
sens que ayant encore énormément de cas
de violence conjugale violences
intrafamiliales il ya aussi les deux
le décrochage chez les jeunes filles
plus que le gars moins que les gars sont
dus à sion et on sait le fus que la
prostitution juvénile s'est énormément
de défis nous assignons nettement après
la nôtre première année d'existence on
faisait des
invention direct mais on a réalisé tout
de suite que la communauté élever
énormément de problèmes et que pour
faire un changement significatif de la
communauté maghrébine au québec on ne
peut plus continuer de fonctionner de
cette manière alors on va faire une
nouvelle orientation
on ne commençait à sensibiliser et
accompagner déjà les partenaires d'état
il disait sitution que ça soit des
écoles et c'est l'essai des centres
jeunesse des milieux de la santé et
services sociaux pour aller faire
comprendre le parcours migratoire la
comédienne agrumes et pour le faire
comprendre que les enjeux qu'il ville
attendait maghrébine et ses 15 à
certains partenaires ce soir politique
or de d2 potentiel à long terme
attribuée par don est ce que votre votre
nouvelle orientation est ce que ça fait
un changement dans l'attitude de des
services des services de l'état
québécois parce que vous avez vous donne
un exemple par exemple les colocs
le colosse social très longues racines
organise chaque année depuis 2000
2016 c'est après le rapport synthèse est
envoyé directement aux différents
ministères devaient pallier le
gouvernement se soit sortir le
gouvernement fait les provinciales et
municipales et le grand bourg en
considération surtout les
recommandations les thèmes qu'on propose
chaque année ce sont des des enjeux et
qui les interpelle aussi c'est lorsqu'on
parle de la construction identitaire des
jeunes malgré là lorsqu'on parle de la
violence conjugale lorsqu'on parle de le
développement de pouvoir d'agir lorsque
rampal de la migration et la santé ce
sont des enjeux très pertinent et c'est
les interpelle alors nous on soutient
les démarches déjà qu'ils le font et ils
avaient besoin d'un organiste qui a une
notoriété qui est le savoir faire et les
composés d'ailleurs parlé que des
professionnels des gens qui vient de
milieux de services sociaux de la santé
s'ils côté
le juriste alors le travail rend fait
deuxième chose que j'aimerais souligner
c'est que racine dans le peu de temps
qu'il existe hélas des ententes
stratégiques avec les grands instituts
de recherche au québec avec des
universités avec plusieurs des deux
paliers de gouvernement alors c'est
quand même je pense qu on est dans le
bon chemin pour atteindre l'objectif
qu'on voulait c'est celui de faire un
changement s'est cassé ou de la
communauté maghrébine sont doublés le
travail qui se fait déjà sur le terrain
merci pour toutes ces explications n'ont
donc je précise que pour votre événement
de ce dimanche
il se passera sur internet à cause de la
perte d'amy parce qu'on ne peut pas les
gens ne peuvent ou ne peuvent pas se se
regrouper dans des salles en ce moment
je voulais vous poser une question par
rapport aux événements héros zonage
on rend beaucoup d'hommages dans les
communautés pas que dans la communauté
maghrébine
il ya pratiquement quand il avait pas la
pandémie est pratiquement 7 et chaque
fin de semaine y avait un hommage
quelques pas
comment éviter que ces hommages
deviennent du folklore ce qu'on trouve
que les gens prennent des séries avec
les politiciens et tout le monde est
content mais ya rien de suisse est juste
pour la pauvre la galerie comment
comment rentrer ça utile à la communauté
c'est une très bonne question en ce sens
même très bonne question honnêtement je
fais de la politique
j'étais très impliqué et malheureusement
avant de répondre à votre question
malheureusement la communauté maghrébine
et le second tellement facilement et est
presque gratuitement avec une seule fait
avec une publication dans un journal
avec celle un milieu l'autre mais on
gagne rien quand collectivement comme
ceux comme communauté rien on n'a pas un
pouvoir
cet événement dommage mais je dois dire
avec tout le monde il est pas aussi
folklorique que certains
le fond nous il ya tout un processus
d'abord d'abord deuxième chose
l'événement et l'état y mettra un député
ou un député de l'assemblée nationale
12e chose il ya tout un processus pour
que le ya un suivi à faire non on fait
pas juste lollia le nom mais le
lorientais qui sait finir on continue de
créer un lien avec ces femmes lors quand
cette année on le dira peut-être dans
une autre rencontre cette année et
plusieurs des femmes le conte à
quelqu'un qui a été choisie cette année
ils ont déjà des ambitions de faire le
saut en politique
alors c'est ça le travail qu en fait en
caux.les si on dirait deux parties on se
met pas dans ça le plus important c'est
de la quantité
il faut faire le saut en politique pour
que ces femmes là puisse faire votre
influence et leur entourage
donc vous encourager les femmes à
s'impliquer politiquement mais
indépendamment du parti politique vous
sans vous intéresse pas qu'il soit de
gauche de droite
l'essentiel c'est qu'elle s'implique un
ajout important cette année quand même
je lui rends bien souligné vu la conduit
que la société vie et tout le monde
demande si ces années les lauréates
aussi ce sont des lauréates qui ont
travaillé beaucoup
dans durant la pandémie dans des
services qui les considéraient qu'ils
sont considérés essentiels alors
vraiment là on a suivi la réalité de la
société alors que des femmes ce sont des
femmes qui entrent et fort depuis le
début de la pandémie dans des services
considérés essentiels
on imagine que ce sont les travailleurs
des premières lignes
je vous dirais c'est possible c'est
entrevue alors ce sont des femmes qui
travaillent nos milieux de l'éducation
la santé le le coordinateur la recherche
alors une santé mentale
on a hâte à dimanche pour voir la liste
des lauréates
merci marc baronne je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association
racines l'association racines qui oeuvre
pour le développement sociétés
maghrébines plaisir